what's up y'all we are back with Ally
Wong Give It Up
here where we dive into the things we
love called obsessions uh but while
we're obsessed with many things there
are also things that we are just not
into so today in honor of Ali's new show
beef which is incredible and you can see
now on Netflix we are bringing you Kelly
and Ally can't stand it
[Music]
here's how it works
and our super creepy supercomputer will
search through the things that bother us
most because it totally knows that
um then Ali or I will get to rant about
why we can't stand whatever topic
appears on the screen I will start here
we go
okay I don't like sound in general let's
talk about sound in general movies and
shows for some reason recently
it's gotten like there will be like a
horrible you know an action movie it'll
be like so loud and then you can't hear
the dialogue so you're constantly
chasing the volume that drives me nuts
but the worst is kissing sounds in
movies I don't want to hear
I don't I don't want to hear that it
doesn't sound like kissing
and it sounds like something I don't
want to watch in a room full of people
like it's just like it's just like not
great I don't like kissing sounds I
don't like over it's like it's chance to
win the audio it's a little too it's a
little too like mac and cheese yeah
being made yes and it's just I and you
want to be like oh what a nice moment oh
they finally kissed and instead I'm
grossed out yeah you just hear like
saliva it's like oh my God it's about to
happen and then
and I'm like what in the who kisses like
this does not make anyone want to go out
and find someone it makes you happy that
you're alone and that's not happening
I like it really yeah I think it adds it
makes it more like 3D to me I don't mind
a little bit yeah a little bit
yeah yeah yeah it's a little much yeah
yeah okay here's you
oh my God
it's the worst you are 100 talking about
me oh man we're never gonna go to dim
sum then can they americanize it like is
that that's just like when I go like for
like when I was living in New York and a
bunch of stand-up comics would be like
take me to dim sum I want to go to dim
sum and then we go to dim sum and they'd
be like what is that ew what is that
what is that what is that oh I want to
do that and they're basically asking why
is that not a sandwich and it's like you
ask me need to take you here
also with like with dim sum it's all
pork and shrimp just eat it yeah it's
awesome pork love pork love shrimp yeah
don't love shrimp I'm allergic but like
I love Pork yeah yeah that's good I'm
not that person I will generally try
anything as long as you're like try it
but it's it's mostly just all the
questions I just thought you were gonna
say like you know how people are like I
love like Chinese and then they get like
the the most Americanized basic they're
like I love Indian food it's like
chicken tikka masala right right like
the one dish yeah it's like that's the
thing that I thought you were gonna say
yes yes because that's annoying to me
and I am one of those annoying people
it's one of the people are squeamish I'm
not squeaming and ask a ton of questions
I don't like when people food shame
either when they yeah
why did you just yuck my food now I
gotta eat it yeah and you just you know
very morphed on it yeah anyway okay and
there you go that was so helpful America
you're welcome that
Kelly and Ally can't stand it totally
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
guys I'm going